[موسيقى]
h
الاندرويد اللي بشغل اجهزه بلاك بيري
موبايل يعتبر الاكثر امانا بالاسواق في
برنامج اسمه دي تك هذا برنامج خاص في
البلاك بيري موبايل اللي موجود على الجهاز
الشخص المستخدم بامكانه يتطلع على
كل الابلكيشن الموجوده على الجهاز ويطلع
كل ابلكيشن عم شو بعمل اكسس لشو مثلا اذا
بدخل قاعد على الصور عم بدخل على
المايكروفون عم بدخل على ه بتعطي هذا
الشخص معلومات انه مثلا اذا في فلاش لايت
اللي هو اللوكس اذا عم بدخل على الكونتاك
بدخل على
[موسيقى]
المايكروفون اللي هو جع كل المعلومات
بمنطقه واحده اما كانت البرامج السوشال
نتورك او الايميل او اي تواصل موجود او
المكالمات في مكان واحد سو الشخص بقدر
يوصل له المعلومات في مكان
واحد